in einer Welt in der sich Mensch und
Technologie immer enger verpflichten
kann es schon mal passieren dass wir
Menschen unsere ursprünglichen Wurzeln
aus den Augen verlieren bevor sich bei
uns Primaten nämlich der sogenannte
opponierbare Daumen entwickelt hat der
entgegengesetzt zu den anderen Finger
ist war der Daumen nur ein weiterer
Finger und Hände waren keine Greifer
sondern eher Haken mit denen man sich
nur von ASS zu Ast hangeln konnte erst
diese Entwicklung ermöglichte es den
Menschen Stöcke Excel Schwerter Hammer
und natürlich Handys zu bedienen so ein
Daumen ist schon der krasse Sache wie
wäre das also einfach zwei davon an
einer Hand zu haben das würde dann nicht
nur schön symmetrisch aussehen sondern
vielleicht auch die Art ändern wie wir
mit der Umgebung interagieren
Instrumente spielen Elektronik bedienen
Rätsel lösen Inspiration für dieses
Video habe ich aus diesen Beitrag von
Daniel Cloud aus dem auf diese Beispiele
von gerade eben stand in diesem Video da
sieht jeder einfach so glücklich aus mit
seinem extra darum und so glücklich will
ich auch sein aber vor allem will ich
rausfinden wie es ist einfach zwei
Daumen an einer Hand zu haben was das
mit meinem Kopf anstellt und ob das
wirklich so leicht in diesen Beitrag
aussieht also brauche ich jetzt auch so
einen dritten Daumen
dieses Video wird unterstützt vom Google
Pixel 7 Pro mehr dazu später
funktioniert und das sieht ja aus wie
einfach ein weicher Kunststoff Daumen
durch den also ohne stallseilen dünnes
durchgefädelt wurde das Stahlseil ist
wiederum auf dem Motor aufgewickelt und
wenn sich das halt zusammen zieht dann
bewegt sich der Daumen durch diese Keile
da so nach innen und greift quasi Dani
oder Danny Cloud die diesen Daumen hier
gemacht hat benutzt im Schuh so ein
Knopf um das Greifen auszulösen finde
ich aber ein bisschen unelegant zuerst
wollte ich das also über Muskel oder
Gehirnströme machen dann ist mir aber
aufgefallen dass ich die Schule ja für
meinen Youtube Kanal abgebrochen habe
noch bevor ich 100 Abonnenten hatte ich
deshalb noch nie in der Uni von innen
gesehen habe und deswegen auch keine
Muskeln oder Hirnströme habt aber da
hatte ich auch schon den nächsten
einfallen das ganze wieder mit so einem
Gummiband hier gehalten also kann man
einfach ein kleines zugmessgerät aus
einer Waage einbauen das automatisch
Mist wie viel Spannung da drauf ist wenn
man jetzt den echten Daumen nach innen
bewegt lässt die Spannung nach und wenn
man den wieder nach außen bewegt dann
nehmen sie halt wieder dazu die sind
Informationen ließ dieses kleine Teil
hier gerade aus und die können wir
später einfach eins zu eins auf diesen
anderen Daumen übertragen und wenn man
dann doch mal nur den extra Raum bewegen
will reicht wenn man den richtigen
Daumen nach innen zieht und das
funktioniert auch noch ist wie genau der
Daumen der motorisiert wird das kann man
später davor brauchen wir erstmal 3D
Modell von der Hand als Referenz um das
alles zu konzentrieren und wir nehmen
natürlich nicht an sondern meine Drums
kenne ich dir jetzt einfach mit
Fotogramm Mitspieler findet man ganz
viel worauf müssen die Bilder die ich
jetzt in dem Google Pixel mache und zwar
von jedem erdenklichen Winkel
[Musik]
Alter da waren wir voll das heftige
Focus Tracking
so von der Hand sind jetzt genug Bilder
was lohnt sich gleich als grobe Referenz
den Daumen allerdings dann hätte ich
gern eins zu eins genauso wie er halt
wirklich ist mit allen Details deswegen
gehe ich das noch näher ran und wenn ich
jetzt hier nah ran gehe erkennt das
automatisch dass ich in den Makro-Modus
gehen will und ich kann ja so nah mein
Daumen reingehen dass mir Details sieht
die man überhaupt nicht sehen will der
wird geil Elektromotor das ist einfach
komplett insane weil er ist einfach
wirklich winzig dieses Bauteile z.B die
meine Kamera nicht scharfstellen will
habe ich immer fotografiert und man kann
die Zahl mit bloß im Auge kaum lesen
aber ja also ich glaube das kann man gut
lesen dann noch ein paar von weiter weg
und daraus mache jetzt gerade Modelle
die Software am Computer errechnet
daraus dann eine Wolke aus einzelnen
dreidimensionalen Punkten aus denen dann
mit etwas Nachbearbeitung ein sehr
feines 3D Modell entsteht hat recht
lange gedauert ist aber echt geil
geworden und auch wenn ihr euch das
wahrscheinlich nicht vorstellen könnt
sieht das mit Textur und realistischem
Licht sogar noch gruseliger aus selbes
Spiel dann mit der Hand nur nicht ganz
so detailliert aber es ist mindestens
genauso gruselig seine eigene Hand im
Computer zu sehen hier kann ich meine
Hand jetzt genau vermessen außerdem kann
ich schon mal den Daumen und die Hand
zusammenbringen um zu schauen was genau
die richtige Positionierung ist aber was
daran so richtig nützlich ist ist dass
ich die Halterung für den Daumen genau
um meine persönliche Handform darum
konzentrieren kann ich habe dafür jetzt
hier auf drei verschiedenen Ebenen grob
die Form von meiner Hand nachgezeichnet
und verbinde jetzt zu einer Schale dann
noch ein bisschen
und abrunden super geschwungene Form
aber dadurch passt halt genau die Hand
und sowas hättest du halt niemals
irgendwie manuell ausmessen kann aber um
zu schauen ob das jetzt wirklich passt
drucken es erstmal ein 3D Drucker hier
ist es jetzt sieht mega geil aus voll
die organische Form gefällt mir sehr gut
der 3D Druck ist auch richtig gut
geworden nur wenn man ultra na angeht
sieht man die einzelnen Unebenheiten der
druckschichten aber mit bloßen Augen
sieht man das nicht sieht echt zehn von
zehn aus und passt es passt irgendwie
angegossen es hat jetzt genau die Form
von meiner Hand aber dadurch fällt da
drunter das muss ein bisschen länger
sitzen damit fest ist aber abgesehen
davon ist die Passung hier echt super
das glaube ich auch echt ziemlich bequem
dann ich habe auch sogar noch eine Idee
wie ich sogar den Prototypen so ein
bisschen hingekriegt einmal ein bisschen
heiße Luft
und schon lässt sich das gut verbiegen
und schon hältst fehlt noch der
eigentliche Daumen dafür überarbeite ich
die Halterung zuerst noch mal so damit
später der Daumen auch dran befestigt
werden kann und füge einen kleinen Kanal
hinzu indem ich nur unsichtbar gefühlt
wird den eingescannten Daumen jetzt
ordentlich zu bearbeiten ist etwas
schwierig weil er so komplex ist also
konstruiere ich erst die Teile die nicht
am Daumen sein sollen zuerst die
keilförmigen Aussparungen damit der
Daumen einknicken kann und mehrere
Löcher am äußeren Ende wo später die
Schnur durchgefädelt wird mit der der
Daumen gebeugt wird dieser
Negativabdruck wenn man so will sieht
jetzt so aus und genau diesen Teil
schneide ich jetzt aus dem komplexen
Daumen Modell heraus übrig bleibt dann
das hier ein super detaillierter Daumen
mit exakt den Masken Einlassungen bereit
für den 3D Druckern
[Musik]
Alter das sieht so falsch aus einfach
und es fühlt sich einfach falsch anders
es fühlt sich das ist halt quasi Gummi
und es fühlt sich halt einfach an wie
ein Daumen und das ist jetzt auch eine
genaue exakte Kopie von meinem Daumen es
ist super gruselig die Tatsache dass es
durch hier ist macht das Ganze noch
krasser riecht ein bisschen komisch ja
es sieht auf jeden Fall falsch aus aber
ich finde es super faszinierend echt
cool geworden ganz viele andere Drucke
hier fertig geworden aber da kommen wir
gleich später dazu wir konzentrieren uns
jetzt erstmal auf diesen zu Mechanismus
dafür muss ich jetzt diese Schnur hier
einmal in den Daumen reinfädeln und dann
ziehe ich das mal durch
[Musik]
maximal gruselig warum kommen jetzt noch
so ein kleiner Silikonschlauch drauf der
elektrisch leitend ist Touchs bedienen
kann weil die funktioniert so dass sie
so eine kleine elektrische Ladung
aufnehmen und diese Schnur die jetzt
quasi hier in den Darm steckt die kommen
jetzt auch hier in diese Halterung rein
das ist richtig geil weil jetzt kann man
diese Schnur hier entlang ziehen und man
sieht überhaupt nicht wo die ist wenn
ich jetzt hier dran ziehen
bewegt sich der Daumen oder gehe sogar
wieder nach oben ja das heißt der ist
straff genug das war noch wichtig
geil Alter
[Musik]
teil
wirklich sehr krasses Teil ey das ist so
lustig es ist auch ein bisschen gruselig
also ziemlich gruselig sogar selbst wenn
man natürlich nicht immer hier anziehen
deswegen immer den Sensor ähm ja und
dann schreibe ich jetzt hier noch mal
von innen dran
ich finde ehrlich gesagt echt dass das
immer mehr aussieht wie so Cyborg Zeug
jetzt hier schon Kabel dran das
Gummiband
cool wie das jetzt langsam aber sicher
einen schönen halt hat und nicht mehr so
rumwackelt kommen jetzt noch mal so ein
Band dahin das fehle ich auch wieder so
durch und der Sensor der muss natürlich
jetzt auch immer steuern und dafür habe
ich hier noch das Ding gebastelt das ist
eine Halterung für so ein Motor das
sieht so verrückt aus das ist richtig
krank und der Motor soll jetzt quasi
dieses Drahtseil hier Aufwickeln ich
habe noch die verschiedenen Größe
Seilwinden Räder gebaut der Motor hat
hier vorne dran so ein Gewinde und aber
auch von Zahnrad da mache ich hier ein
Pixel kurz fünf Sachen und gehe hier
rüber zum Lötkolben und macht dieses
Zahnrad jetzt einmal richtig schön heißt
jetzt drücke ich das Teile quasi drauf
schraubt rein und das zieht sich jetzt
da hoffentlich dran und durch die Hitze
schmilzt da jetzt rein und durch die
Hitze hat es eben nicht nur eine
Schraube sondern ist hier auch richtig
schön reingeschmolzen ins Zahnrad mir
gerade wahrscheinlich schon gemerkt die
letzten 1 bis 2 Minuten schon mit dem
Google Pixel 7 Vorstand mit einem
normalen Kamera das mehrere tausend Euro
kostet und hätte ich nicht aufgeklärt
wäre wahrscheinlich gar nicht
aufgefallen ziemlich krass was mit den
Technik kann 4k 60 FPS und natürlich
auch Weitwinkel also muss ich gerade
keine objektiv extra machen
hier motorisiert bewegen kann davor muss
ich den hier allerdings am
computerprogrammieren
das ist wieder die Gerätschaft von
vorhin die Pascal zusammengebaut hat
damit kann ich jetzt kalibrieren indem
ich einmal den Daumen nach außen macht
dann den Knopf drück
dann den Daumen ganz nach innen macht
und dann noch mal den Knopf drückt
[Musik]
und jetzt haben wir nicht mehr wieder
unseren Graph wie vorhin den ich gerade
hier eingeblendet wird wenn ich in
meinen Daumen nach oben unten mache oder
hier nach innen sondern ihr hört gerade
schon
der Schrittmotor dreht sich jetzt auch
hingehen dann dreht sich der Motor
genauso wie ich mich bewegt
[Musik]
es ist schon echt krass wie gut das hier
funktioniert unser einfach nur
weil hier hinten dieses Teil das alles
erkennen ich nehme das jetzt mal auf dem
Arm jetzt muss ich nur noch irgendwie
diese Stahlseil da rein gefehlt kriegen
das Problem ist gerade
einfach zu sehr verrutscht das muss
eigentlich oben bleiben weil sonst
verrutscht das und der Zug vom Salz
zieht das Teil runter und nicht den
Daumen nach dem kurze Verbesserungen
ein bisschen schwierig zu kommen
[Musik]
einfach wild
ja es ist krass
es erlaubt ein Mensch und Sachen die man
sonst nicht kann aber Sachen mit zwei
Daumen festhalten und dann drehen mit
den Zeigefingern
die schlau ist es damit jetzt ein Messer
zu nehmen
lol
[Musik]
es ist schon praktisch dass die Daumen
einfach innen sind weil man sieht
einfach beide immer man sieht beide
Daumen immer aber der Daumen ist immer
von der Hand verdeckt und ich sehe
überhaupt nichts das ist so krass das
ist so eine Tatsache an einem zweiten
Daumen pro Hand die ich einfach niemals
berücksichtigt hätte
ja so in der Hand das heißt das hier
müsste ja
so sein
ja doch es geht theoretisch
bisschen schwieriger allerdings man
müsste echt meinen dass es super easy ne
er muss echt nochmal alles neu lernen
das ist krass
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
ja
mega gut überhaupt nicht umständlich
überhaupt nicht gruselig
[Musik]
also man kriegt auch langsam Gefühle für
das ist so gruselig was ist das was ist
das oh mein Gott
[Musik]
für Instagram machen will kann ich damit
ein Handy bedienen was ich jetzt
probieren will ein Foto machen kann
[Musik]
funktioniert
nein leider nicht das schade
ob das mit diesen leitfähigen nutzen
hier vorne funktioniert hat damit ich
hier auch quasi Fotos machen kann und
generell einfach am Handy bedienen
könnte
let's go das funktioniert es total geil
dass diese spezielle funktioniert zack
jetzt ist ja dieses hässliche Teil da
jetzt mal auf bearbeiten
gehe rüber zum magischen Radierer diesen
apfel-rester ein wenig zum retuschieren
aus dieses schwarze Dinge auch noch
ja sehr gut und schon ein Bild von Apfel
das Feature ist praktisch hat man sonst
umständlich am PC ein Bild ja aber das
Programm machen müssen aber so cool das
Teil ist mir ist es nicht so richtig
eingefallen wofür das Mega sinnvoll sein
könnte müsste man auf jeden Fall noch
upgraden also erstens ja das Ding sollte
halt nicht einfach verbrennen das ist
schon ein Vorteil dann das Original das
kann sich ja nicht nur so einziehen
sondern auch noch so drehen das ist auch
glaube ich viel praktischer danach und
ich habe am Anfang gesagt dass ich es
ohne elegant findest das Ding mit den
Füßen zu steuern aber ich glaube dass
das trotzdem noch ein bisschen leichter
zu steuern ist als das Teil hier aber
trotzdem Spaß gemacht und waren extrem
Bilder Erfahrung alle Infos zum Google
Pixel 7 Pro findet in der
Videobeschreibung und ich bin damit raus